first we're continuing to follow the
investigation of a police shooting near
downtown las vegas police have been on
the scene for five hours it's not too
far from fremont and sahara that's where
we find victoria saha for more on this
developing story at 11.
yes denise it's been a very active scene
here in front of riviera mobile home
parks police tell us they were
responding to a burglary but it quickly
turned into a police shooting
police say when they responded to the
burglary they found a man with a gun
officers requested he put down his gun
but he refused to listen and that's when
police say he started waving the gun at
them which made police shoot him this
man later died at the hospital though
police could not confirm if he lived in
this mobile home community we spoke to a
resident here who lived right next door
to this man he wanted to remain
anonymous but says this man was having a
very emotional day
my roommate was right there and he
called me immediately and said hey you
know mike's walking around waving the
gun at the cops i tried to get home in
time
to try to talk him down too late
police could not say how many times this
man was shot but say multiple officers
fired their gun this is the fifth police
shooting for the department residents
were first forced excuse me to leave the
mobile home park for hours but they are
now back inside we were told this is
going to be quite a while until police
clear up the scene here reporting live
tonight victoria zaha live local now